Oh
my personal interest in autism dates
from when I was a child and I had a
friend whose brother was quite strange
and when I was in medical school I
realized that he had autism he was
actually well actually Asperger's he was
a very bright kid never looked you in
the face constantly was throwing his
arms up like like that as though he'd
made some great discovery and knew
everything about baseball statistics and
so I made an imprint on me at an early
age and it was sort of a wonderful it
was sort of a wonderful thing to see
this fellow who actually grew up I think
to have a successful career as a disc
jockey
so I was always always interested in
autism and and because I come from a
family that's somewhat left-wing always
looking for ways I can do something
that's a benefit to society and it
struck me that autism was not a disorder
that was studied by the scientific
community very deeply but it in the
worst cases it was as tragic for the
families that had an autistic child so I
was motivated in by both of those things
to have an interest in autism and when
we began to study cancer which was in
the early 1980s I knew at the time they
were studying cancer that the tools that
we were developing could later be
applied to genetic disorders not the
kind of genetic disorders where you
inherit something from your parents but
the kind of genetic disorders that arise
spontaneously because of mutation in the
parents germline
an example of those kinds of mutation
that everybody is familiar with its Down
syndrome or trisomy 21 I guess is the
politically correct way to refer to it
these are new mutations you don't
inherit it and the can in the classical
sense but it was you know obvious to
people who thought about it that the
human genome is not static it changes
over time that's how we evolved and most
of those change
are not good they result in some
disorder or another but they're hard to
study most people who study genetic
disorders study inherited kinds of
genetic asaurus I was interested in the
other kind of genetic disorders that
result from new mutation and new
mutations what we study when we look at
cancers when we're comparing a cancer to
the normal person's genome the cancers
differ by new mutation that's called
somatic mutation the same tools that
find somatic mutation can find germline
mutations if you compare the child to
the parents the incidence of autism
being relatively high and by and large
these children are so different from
their parents it seemed to me that it
was likely just a priori that autism was
the result of new mutation in the
germline possibly affecting many many
many genes that result in the same end
behavior or similar end behaviors and
that that was it being ignored by the
community so when we had the tools to go
look at this we did so and so it was a
combination of opportunism because we
had developed the tools and intrinsic
interests both from a social point of
view the social good and also from a
personal point of view that is I've had
a personal interest in how does the
brain go from being sort of what we
would recognize as belonging to a normal
person to somebody who's in wondrous
ways very different from us